WESLEY CHUN:
Greetings, developers,
and welcome to Serverless
Migration Station, where
we show you one serverless
computer modernization
technique.
I'm Wesley Chun at
Google, joined by Martin
and our friend Porter here
to take you from point A
to point B. Today's migration
represents a product crossover
showing you how to
containerize your App Engine
apps to run on Cloud Run, our
serverless container hosting
service.
MARTIN: Wow, that sounds
pretty complicated.
Containerizing your app?
I'm just a simple web developer.
How much do I have to
learn about containers?
WESLEY CHUN: Great
question, Martin.
Developers out there
already familiar with Docker
don't have much to learn since
they've already been creating
and deploying containers.
Using Docker to create a
container for Cloud Run
is pretty much the
same as anywhere else.
On the other hand, if you're
completely new to containers,
don't worry, we'll
take care of you, too.
In this module 4 video,
we'll focus on Docker.
But in module 5,
we'll show you how
to containerize your apps
without having to know anything
about Docker or containers.
MARTIN: That's great to know
that Google Cloud is for Docker
veterans and container newbies.
So for folks like
me who are new,
what's the elevator pitch
for containers anyway?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, I'm
glad you asked, Martin.
With a seed planted
years ago, containers
came to the forefront
when virtualization
became a thing around the
beginning of the millennium,
and were accelerated
specifically
for application packaging
about a decade later by Docker.
Of course, programming has been
around for longer than that.
And some of us have been
writing code for ages
without containers.
While optional, containerizing
gives developers
the most freedom and flexibility
in bundling their app.
They're easily reproducible,
and you can use or reuse them
anywhere you want, making
them extremely portable, too.
MARTIN: Come on.
Those are just marketing
buzzwords, Wes.
What do they mean for
developers like us?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, you asked
for the elevator pitch.
This is going to take a little
longer than one elevator ride
now.
Well, containers give you the
flexibility to bundle whatever
your apps need, freeing you
from traditional serverless
restrictions like, you
have to use this language,
or you can't muddle that
library because it's in C++.
Furthermore, the
container is reproducible.
You can figure how the
container is built.
And if you use the
same instructions,
you could create an
identical container.
This is valuable, not
just for testing, but also
for verifying your
app works with which
versions of your dependencies.
No more deploying apps and
hoping the production libraries
are compatible.
MARTIN: OK, so my users are
based all over the world.
So I want to deploy the
same service everywhere.
Also, if I had a
bad build, I want
to roll back to the
previous working version.
So the same container image
can be deployed anywhere?
And if there's a
problem, I can roll back
to a previous container image?
WESLEY CHUN: Oh, for sure.
I mean, I know we're
talking serverless here.
But realize containers
are ultra portable,
as that same container image
can be deployed to your Compute
Engine VMs, Kubernetes, in
the cloud, your VMs on-prem,
hybrid, or even multi-cloud.
Think of containers
like a shopping bag
to bundle your code
and its dependencies.
Imagine carrying everything
you bought at the market
separately to your
car or on the subway.
MARTIN: [CHUCKLES] That
shopping-bag analogy
makes a lot of sense to me.
I'm sold on containers.
But do I have to containerize
my App Engine apps?
I'm kind of used to App Engine's
style of development, where
I improve my code, I
deploy to staging, and then
eventually to production.
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, as
I mentioned earlier,
I've been writing apps for
years without containers.
So if you're comfortable
there, that's fine.
But realize that industry
has moved towards containers
in a big way so they're there
for you when you're ready.
I think you'll like
our next video, though,
because we'll show you
how to containerize apps
without knowing much
about containers.
So stay tuned for that.
For now, Google has
expressed long-term support
for App Engine.
But much of our effort
is going to Cloud Run
because containers are
a de facto standard now.
MARTIN: Well, I'm ready now.
But before that, I do have
some Python 2 legacy apps.
I know it's been deprecated
by the community and all that.
But so I'm concerned.
Do you have any options for me?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah,
you're not alone, Martin.
Many Python 2 developers
share those concerns.
However, that long-term support
page links to another page
where Google has committed to
supporting the App Engine 2.7
runtime, letting
you move when ready.
And did you already
forget that Cloud Run
supports any language,
any library, any binary?
Containerizing is one way to
keep your Python 2 app alive
forever.
MARTIN: Well, if you
put it that way, Wes,
I'm going to containerize two
App Engine apps, the Python 2
Cloud NDB app from module 2 and
the Python 3 Cloud Datastore
app from module 3.
WESLEY CHUN: Sure, Martin.
Porter has lots of
energy today, so we'll
do both, which is why there
are Python 2 and 3 folders
for module 4 when we're done.
Check out the module 2 or
3 videos and repo folders
to refamiliarize
ourselves with each.
The Python 2 Cloud NDB up
is in the module 2a folder
while the Python
3 Cloud Datastore
app is in the module 3b folder.
Let's pause for a moment
for you to catch up and grab
your starting codebase.
Got it?
Great.
Now let's go containerize them.
As with most migrations,
it's always a good idea
to check that you're
starting from a working
app, whether the module
2 Cloud NDB Python 2
app or the module 3 Cloud
Datastore Python 3 app,
please redeploy yours--
or ours, as suggested moments
ago-- with gcloud app deploy,
and verify it works where
you get the same output
as from previous modules.
Changing products from
App Engine to Cloud Run
requires configuration
changes, so we
suggest you make a full copy
of your working app folder.
Now it's safe to make
the necessary changes
containerizing that app.
First, delete the app.yaml file
that is not used in Cloud Run.
If migrating the Python 2 Cloud
NDB app, also delete App Engine
config.py and the lib folder,
more App Engine artifacts
unused in Cloud Run.
Next let's tackle
requirements.txt.
App Engine and Cloud Functions
are an source-based instructor
app with a
production-ready server.
Since Cloud Run is a bit more
DIY, you need to roll your own.
Python Engine uses the gunicorn
production-ready server
if you don't specify your own.
So let's use that
one for Cloud Run
by adding it to
requirements.txt.
I like to put my packages in
lowest- to highest-level order,
which is why I listed it first.
For the Python 2 app,
you'll have gunicorn, flask,
and cloud-ndb, whereas
for the Python 3 app,
it'll be gunicorn, flask
and cloud-datastore.
Version numbers are
a good practice.
However, they change a lot and
differ between Python 2 and 3.
So that's why we're
not showing any here.
They're in the
repo files though.
When using Docker,
the main config
file your need is a Docker file.
So create that with the
content you see on screen
or download it from the repo.
If you're new to
Docker files, you
need to start with a base
container, in this case
a minimal Python 2 or 3 image.
From here, create and cd
into your working directory,
arbitrarily called "app,"
with the WORKDIR command.
Now copy all the
source code into app
and run pip install so
your application can
use those packages listed
in requirements.txt.
Finally, ENTRYPOINT
tells the system
to start gunicorn
to serve your app.
Check the Dockerfile best
practices page for more info.
Another good practice is
to add a dockerignore file.
While it is optional, it
helps keep unnecessary files
from being added
to your container.
It's less important
for our sample apps
since they're so small, but
it can have a positive impact
on your apps, controlling
container size
and preventing accidental
exposure of secrets like API
keys or OAuth credentials.
This isn't
Python-related, so you
can use the same dockerignore
for both Python 2 and 3 apps.
Since we're migrating
identical apps to Cloud Run,
there are no other changes other
than configuration updates.
That means we can
just deploy it now.
We're done.
Instead of gcloud app
deploy for App Engine,
the command now is gcloud
run deploy SVC_NAME,
dash-dash-source, dot to
deploy the app from the source
code in the current directory.
Instead of deploying
an app, with Cloud Run,
you deploy a service.
So you have to come up with
a service name, hopefully
more exciting than App
Engine's "default."
Cloud Run also has more options.
So you're going to be asked
what region to deploy to
and whether you're allowing
open internet traffic.
Lastly, Cloud Run is available
in other form factors,
but the one closest to App
Engine is fully managed.
If you don't want to get asked
all of these every single time,
provide them on the command
line as options, like this one
here that I'm using for our app,
calling the service visitme.
And like your App
Engine app, your service
should be available
globally in under a minute
at a unique URL you can point
to with the custom domain.
Hit it with your browser
and confirm you now
have a running Cloud Run app.
Cool.
So what do you think, Martin?
MARTIN: Wow, Wes, that
was way easier than I
thought it was going to be.
I was a bit apprehensive about
learning these containers,
but it doesn't look that bad.
But watching you
do it is too easy.
Where can I try these
migrations myself?
WESLEY CHUN: Of course, Martin.
All modules have a
corresponding codelab
linked in the repo
and below, where
we walk through this
migration step by step.
If things don't go well
migrating the Python 2 Cloud
NDB app, grab it again from
the module 2a Start folder.
The same is true with the
Python 3 Cloud Datastore app.
Reset to its module 3b
folder if you need to.
You can compare your
solution with ours
in the module 4a or
4b Finish folders.
Another link we're leaving
for you is to the gcloud run
deploy docs in case you're
curious how it works
and what else you
can do with it.
MARTIN: Great.
I'm looking forward to
doing those by hand.
But I am still concerned
about that Dockerfile.
Our sample app is quite simple,
so there wasn't any trouble.
But you know, out
in the real world--
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, I know.
You have many more
dependencies and it's
easier to create suboptimal or
overly complex Docker files.
These can lead to
slowing down the build,
deployment, and execution
of your containerized app.
That's why you should
check out module 5 where
you don't have to worry
about Dockerfiles anymore.
We'll add a link to the
video once it's ready.
But for now, you can
already do its codelab.
MARTIN: Oh, I look
forward to seeing that.
By the way, my DevOps
coworkers told me
they prefer it if my app can be
integrated in a CI/CD pipeline.
Can Cloud Run do that, Wes?
WESLEY CHUN: Oh yeah.
On the CD side, one cool
feature of Cloud Run
is that you can deploy
direct from a code push.
This is configured
in the Cloud Console
if your code is in a repo
system like GitHub or Bitbucket.
When a commit takes place,
it triggers Cloud Build
to build and register
your container,
then deploys it to Cloud Run.
If you slip in a service
like GitHub actions
that builds and tests your code
before sending it to Cloud Run,
you'll have that CI/CD
environment you asked for.
See the link to our
community tutorial
to learn more about
how to do that.
MARTIN: OK, great.
Thanks, Wes.
Aside from containerizing
my App Engine apps
for Cloud Run, what are
some other migrations I
should consider?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, aside
from the next video
on containerizing your app
without Docker, if you're
on Cloud NDB and have other
code using the Cloud Datastore
client library,
consider consolidating
to one client library.
That's covered in module 3.
If you're excited about
all those Firebase
features in Cloud Firestore
and willing to move
your app to a new project,
check out modules 6 and 10.
If your app uses App Engine task
cues, migrate to Cloud Tasks.
And that's covered in
modules 7, 8, and 9.
Finally, if your App
Engine app is pretty small
or does only one thing, consider
migrating to Cloud Functions.
That'll be found in module 11.
But note you have to port your
code from Python 2 to 3 first,
as Cloud Functions
only supports Python 3.
And thank all of you for
staying with us on all
of these migration journeys.
Please join us for the
module 5 migration station,
not only to learn
more about containers,
but it's all of the stuff
that we didn't get a chance
to cover today.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google Cloud.
On behalf of Martin
and Porter, we
hope to see you at the
next Migration Station
or on another Serverless
Expedition soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]